coincidence there has to be a reason
behind this betweens that someone is
responsible we have to know who cake can
you cannot do that man
what a total Freaky Friday no way man
switch bodies it's more of a quantum
bleep where's the mirror focus just for
a second and take this seriously because
the world thinks that you're Oliver
Queen and that I'm Barry Allen and I
would really like to know why is that
cool thank you I'm sorry weird just if
you could just for 90 seconds of
seriousness you gotta admit this is a
little cool I will find it a lot cooler
when I wake up in my own bed tomorrow
morning you will come in down with Iris
we have to fix this right now who are
you geez wait wait this is Barry and
Oliver they're friends
wait oh so you know that I'm Oliver
Annie's Barry yeah well why wouldn't I
okay
oh you guys this is my cousin Clark I'm
so glad you kissing me your cousin that
cousin the super cousin oh please call
me Clark welcome to our farm are you
puffin on your chest yes Lois Lane Daily
Planet wait why did you guys think I
wouldn't recognize you
well Oh
[Music]
oh well that's new we could use your
help
[Music]
crossovers are just the best boss over
is fun we're sort of having too much fun
Barry and Oliver have body swapped I'm
sorry buddy what Oliver wakes up and
finds out that he is buried I love you
Barry Allen and grant is playing Oliver
Queen so crazy suit up
the suit is it's tight not it's actually
the opposite of tight
I meant tight like cool I forget do you
do I need help putting this on they go
to Cara's earth and I can't for him in
Smallville which was really exciting she
happens to be hanging with her cousin
that cousin this oh please call me Clark
we introduced Lois Lane and she is a
force to be reckoned with
you want to tag along if you don't I
will Smallville there was no way Lois
Lane was gonna miss out on any of the
action my name is Barry Allen John
Wesley Shipp is back in his iconic 1990s
flash costume he's in his original flash
suit I was really jealous actually I
didn't get to be flash that day I was
Green Arrow and Stephen standing in my
flash suit next to Jon ship and I was
just that was devastating we always do
the crossovers with one thing in mind it
really is for the fans the Easter eggs
and fun I feel like we're really giving
it to them more than ever it feels like
make-believe it yeah it's sometimes we
have to remember that word on the job
you freaking see that Gordon our city we
get to meet Batwoman which is awesome
this is an iconic character she's never
been played before I'm trying to do my
best for me and make it as badass and
kick asses I would like that wouldn't be
playing Elseworlds hey everybody its
charlie it's almost time for the
crossover so we got a whole bunch of new
footage to break down there's a couple
different clips just highlighting some
of the funny moments some really huge
Easter eggs and confirming what's going
on with the John Wesley Shipp 90s Barry
Allen so there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the clips on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this the clip at the beginning of
this in the arrow bunker seems like it's
the first time that they're meeting each
other since they've swapped bodies love
the way the Barry gets super nerdy about
it it's not so much body swapping as
much as a quantum leap if you never
watch that TV show it was Sam Beckett
jumping into other people's lives he
would remember who he was he would see
himself when he looked into the mirror
but no one around him in all the
different lives that he visited would
see anything different they wouldn't
know that he was someone else unless he
told them which they get into a little
bit more during the Superman clip where
they had to explain and Oliver has to
show off his flash powers to explain
what's different you also notice in that
clip too they're wearing each others
clothes so they dress like each other
and they said that during the crossover
they kind of have to adopt each other's
mannerisms you see Barry trying to be a
hardcore like Oliver normally is in
Oliver being a little more chilled out
like Barry is when Oliver runs in to
find Barry he's doing the Salmon Ladder
in the ruins of the bunker that's the
funny thing too is that the arrow bunker
got destroyed at the end of arrow last
season it's still broken now so you
notice that none of that has changed but
because Barry is so jazzed up to be
super fit like Oliver is he can do the
Salmon Ladder like a normal person now
instead of using his flash powers so
it's just them paying off that joke from
the first arrow flash crossover when we
met Barry Allen and he was super jealous
of Oliver they start looking at each
other's pictures oh look I got to be
mayor but the thing that really gets him
pissed off is like oh my god we need to
fix this is the thought that Oliver
spent the night with Iris so just having
a little bit of fun with a wife swap of
it all I don't
linger too much on that you get some
more scenes with them in their
respective vigilante costumes Oliver in
the flash costume getting examined by
team flash Barry trying to figure out
how to put on the Green Arrow costume
I don't remember am I supposed to get
help to put this on but we finally get
some scenes with Superman and Lois Lane
we haven't seen a whole lot of footage
with her yet but she gives off a very
good Margot Kidder vibe so I'm liking
what I see from her so far but we don't
know exactly how big her role is during
the crossover because in the poster she
has this giant hammer that she's
wielding so it's like what the hell is
this hammer for and what is it supposed
to do the thing about this scene though
is that it does make you wonder how much
Oliver and Barry respectively know about
Batman and Superman because we know
Oliver knows all about Bruce Wayne based
on some other voiceover dialogue we've
gotten in the trailer so far it sounds
like he's not totally convinced that
Batman exists though like he's the one
that says Batman is a myth Barry is the
one that believes Batman exists because
obviously he's a fanboy he read comics
when he was a little kid like he had
that space goes comic we saw during
season 1 but in this scene here it's not
totally clear if they're learning that
Clark Kent is Superman
for the first time I'm assuming because
we've had a couple crossovers with
Supergirl she's totally explained that
so they're fully up to speed on who he
is they've just never actually met him
in person before and that's why Oliver
is puffing his chest out just because
he's super insecure standing next to a
living god on planet earth the other
really cool thing in this clip is that
they confirm what's going on with John
Wesley ships 90s Barry Allen they
confirmed that he is Barry Allen from
the 90s flash TV show so all the things
that happened on that show now are
cannon to the arrowverse but if you're
confused about how that can work because
genetically he looks like he's identical
to Henry Allen Barry's father so unless
they throw us a curveball and there's a
time-travel situation going on the way
I'm choosing to take this is that yes he
is like Barry's dad Henry Allen but in
earth 90s universe Barry's grandparents
happen to name his father Barry
instead of naming him Henry Allen that's
also how they explained Jay Garrick of
earth 3 looks exactly like Henry Allen
because his parents just happened to
name him Jay Garrick instead of Henry
so you have two different versions of
Barry's dad that became the flash on
different earths through different
circumstances you get a little more
footage of them confronting the monitor
and you get Ruby Rose talking about bat
woman and a little look at her lair
where she keeps her bat woman costume
remember she's not showing up to the
second episode so they actually have
some footage from behind the scenes of
the third episode which is gonna be
Supergirl on Tuesday night
so we'll just remind people about the
schedule as we move through each night
of the crossover that's why I think we
open up with that Stephen Amell in Barry
Allen's bed scene looking at iris like
he doesn't know what's going on
just because there'll be so much stuff
to talk about so many Easter eggs I'll
try to prioritize the videos for the
biggest stuff and then if I need to I'll
do bonus videos just based on special
requests or big questions that you guys
have from each episode there is a really
big spider-man far from home panel
happening this weekend because of all
the Marvel stuff at cc XP if they drop a
trailer I'll totally do a video for it
but we might not get a spider-man far
from home trailer till next week so I'll
just let people know as I post new
Marvel videos congratulations sibrel
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big DC video please email me on the
about page my channel so I can get your
contact details click here to rewatch
the Avengers for endgame
trailer a billion more times and click
here for all my flash crossover videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]